kommen wir zum Oren anlegen, ein sehr
sehr wichtiges Manömer. Wir können rechts und links
Fläche einklappen, zu allererst einmal
Kleider Oren anlegen. Mit angelegte Oren und
Beschleuniger schaffen wir Sinkgeschwindigkeiten von 3
bis Maximum, 3,7 Meter, 3,7 Meter
pro Sekunde sinken, aber wir fliegen dabei
gerade aus. Das heißt, wir haben noch einen
Vorwärtsblugung können, so beispielsweise aus
irgendeinen Bereich, wo man rauswollen
Flüchte. Also sehr effektiv und sehr gut und
sehr einfach. Deshalb soll ich durch Anlegen der
Oren, also das könnt ihr ihr eben
merken, alles was klappt, bremst zu allererst einmal
den Schirm. Wenn man das von der Seite
betrachten, durch Anlegen der Oren, haben wir jetzt
gleiche verringert. Wir bremsen den Schirm
rechts und links auf den äußeren Flügel
ein bisschen ab. Das heißt, unter Anstellung
erhöht sich jetzt was. Jetzt ist das für
uns ein bisschen schlecht, weil mit dem erhöhten
Anstellung, sind wir natürlich langsamer
geworden. Wir haben durch die geringe
Fläche nicht erhöhte Flächenbelastung, also
unser Gewicht ist immer noch gleich geblieben.
Das heißt, das Gewicht pro Quadratmeter Fläche
ist deutlich größer als vorher. Bedeutet auch, dass
der Stolpunkt, also der Punkt, wo wir den
Schirm an Vorwärtsflug hinnen, dass der auch
nach oben gewandert ist. Also der Schöhr geworden.
Ich mache nur ein Beispiel, das stimmt nicht mit der Realität,
aber einfach, dass das das Ganze ein bisschen
nachvollziehen können. Mit geöffnetem Schirm sind wir
beim Stolpunkt von 18 bis 20 kmh, mit
angelegten Oren und größerer Flächenbelastung
sind wir bei 23 bis 25 kmh. Jetzt sind wir aber
langsam geworden, durch den erhöhten Anstelllinkel.
Das bedeutet, unser Fenster, wo vorher so groß
war zum Stolpunkt, ist jetzt kleiner geworden.
Also der Abriss ist
viel einfacher möglich. Zudem ist es ja oft so, dass
wir die Oren dann noch ein bisschen aufbucken
möchte und der Abriss einfach viel schneller vorhanden ist.
Das kombiniert mit zum Beispiel Thermik, wäre dann auch noch
fatal. Aus diesem Grund gibt es bei uns in der
Schulung Oren anlegt immer nur im Verbindung mit dem
Beschleunigen. Denn durch das Beschleunigen
neige ich die Kappe vorne weiter nach unten, ich
verringere als den Anstelllinkel. Ich erhöhe sogar noch
weil die Sinngeschwindigkeit. Und ich bin jetzt mit
meinem oder meinen Abriss Fenster, das ist jetzt wieder etwas
größer geworden. Ich habe wieder mehr Distanz zum Stolpunkt.
Und deshalb gibt es bei uns Oren anlegt immer nur im
Verbindung mit dem Beschleunigen. Gut, wir machen das Ganze Oren anlegen.
Eigentlich sehr simpel. Wir behalten die Brämsamen
stecken in der Hand. Wir richten uns den Beschleuniger,
wer nicht so einfach in den Beschleunigen reinkommt, kann die
Bräms auch in einer Hand nehmen, wenn sich dann den
Beschleunigen richten. Dann gehen die Bräms aber wieder in die
jeweilige Hand über. Dann so nochmal den Beschleuniger treten,
sodass wir bei beiden weinen schön symmetrisch leicht drinnen
stehen, 30 bis 40 Prozent. Jetzt versuchen wir uns zu orientieren.
Wir suchen die äußerste A-Line. Die geht auf der
eigene, einfach weit nach außen zum Schirm.
Geht aber nicht zum Flügelende vom Schirm. Das wäre die
Stahp, der Katholische Schirm.
Wir gehen auf den Schirm.
Geht aber nicht zum Flügelende vom Schirm.
Wir machen das Ganze mit den Beschleuniger treten, sodass wir bei einem
Schirm. Dann gehen die Brämsamen, das ist in der Hand
zu orientieren. Dann gehen wir beim Schirm.
Wir wollen uns etwa auf der andere Seite auf der Verwendung
Also auf der einen waren alle Leinen rot und die stabile Leine auf der bebene war ebenfalls rot, also
nicht sehr klug gewesen. Deshalb versucht euch wirklich zu orientieren, es muss die äußerste
A-Leine sein. Die ist bei A-Schirmen immer einzig aufgehängt. Daher ihr seht, dass eine Leine
hängt alleine an einem Leidenschlosskrank und ist sogar alleine an einem Tragegurt geführt.
Dieser ist oftmals, sogar noch markiert mit einem Fähnchen oder einer anderen Farbe. Also
sollte auch das euch das Ganze ein bisschen vereinfachen, diese Leine zu finden. Dann um diese Leine zu
packen und die Fläche der Robeneint klappen, müsste die so festhalten, dass er den Daumen und
den Zeigefinger oberhalb für diesen Leinen. Und jetzt ist es wichtig, einen Kopf zählen. Wir
wollen sie metrisch ziehen, d.h. dem Kopf zählen, 1, 22, 22, 23 ziehe die Leine nach unten und jetzt
damit mir die Leine nicht unkontrolliert, wieder hoch, schnellst, schnalst, halten wir diese an
Haupttagegurt fest, dort, wo man halt dann sind. Und wenn wir das haben, mit dem Blicken nach oben
sehen, Eierhol, haben wir sauber angedeckt, die oben, dann legen wir Volker aus, d.h. dem
Beschleuniger Volker. Jetzt können wir steuern, nur noch mit Gewichtsverlager rum. Und bei
Gurtzeugen mit Sitzbrett geht das sehr, sehr gut. Bei Gurtzeugen ohne Sitzbrett können wir, wenn
das nicht ausreicht, die Gewichtsverlager rum. Können wir durch Zug am Innerentrag gut, also
richtig transieren, und das Gewicht drauflehnen, können wir den Schirm noch besser ums Eck
bringen. Zu ausleiten, gemäifere neutrale Position, gehen ein bisschen zurück aus dem Gas,
einfach nicht zu viel, so 50 Prozent. Lassen dann die alle einen erstenweise metrisch nach oben
frei. Wenn die Ohren jetzt drinnen sind, d.h. ist wichtig zum Schirm zu schauen, wenn die
Ohren drinnen sind, immer noch, dann lassen wir den Beschleuniger trinkt und punkten einmal kräft,
erinnert sich an die gleichen Belastung, deshalb Beschleuniger drinnen bereiten. Dann einmal punkten,
wenn die Ohren draußen sind, kann man rausgehen, wenn die Ohren immer noch drinnen bleiben,
dann zählt dem Kopf, 21, 22 und erst zwei bis drei Sekunden später kommt, dann
einmal einen Kräftiger trinkt und dann gehen wir raus. Gut, das zum hohen Anliebten.